Looks as if at least one person hasn't lost faith in Justin Bieber.
"Simpsons" creator Matt Groening gave the beleaguered singer a cameo spot...
...on the long-running Fox series showing the 19-year-old singer...
...trying to crash Bart's talent show.
First of all, you're over ten years old.
Second, you're clearly Justin Bieber.
That's another 25 bucks we'll never see.
Gosh!
Of course, the show couldn't help but wink at the audience.
Bieber's "blink and you missed it" spot...
...follows the tradition of dozens of celebrity voice cameos every season.
Others on Sunday's episode include Bill Hader, Jane Krakowski, and Patrick Stewart.
Bieber voiced approval of his Simpsonification on Twitter,...
...welcoming the appearance after some disastrous press during his European tour...
...and looming legal issues in Los Angeles.
Doubling up on the adoring tabloid headlines,...
...he spends Sunday serenading his mother in concert in South Africa.